hey guys this is andrew from
trainsenses.com i'm a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong and i've been working for several
big investment banks like hsbc or
commerce bank
and i've just started to make some
youtube videos where i share with you
guys all my experience
and i try to show you what are the
different techniques that work for me
and for what reason and how to use them
so if you want to know
how to read the markets and which stock
you should invest into
because i'm here to discuss all of this
stuff that you can find everywhere on
the internet you know on reddit on wall
street bet on twitter and up there i'm
hanging out there
and i try to pick up the list of stocks
that for me
look bullish so if you want to know
which one i think are going to go higher
you are in the right place let's get
into it
[Music]
so today i want to talk about ace kt so
you can see this is my shortness
so very quickly guys i'm here you know
on twitter
and you know uh wall street bats so i've
been showing you uh guys this already in
my
previous videos and i'm analyzing all
the stocks
that i see and i'm trying to share with
you guys my levels you know my support
level my resistance level and i'm trying
to
tell you if for me it is a good or not
here is my short list i think that all
of those
have interesting uh things to do doesn't
mean you should just buy it let's
discuss
this first so uh once again guys i'm
very focused on the market
capitalization and the short interest
market capitalization
makes the stock a possible target for
these guys that hang out on these forums
and as they did for gme as they did with
amc and as they want to do with many
more stocks
and the short interest is very important
to notice as well
because this is what might create a
short squeeze so once again guys what is
happening for the stocks is that they
have earnings you know going
lower you can see for example this is
skt
all right so the earnings are just
dropping heavily google
is same thing guys so this is the reason
why the hedge funds are getting those
stocks
and i'm here to tell you guys what i see
if
i think that it's uh some nice levels to
buy but once again if you have some
short interest that is massive
and a low cut market capitalization this
makes it possible for a short squeeze
so let's start with skt guys so this
one i have two different information so
you know the technique i use i love like
being on the logarithmic scale and doing
some
trend line when the trendline is broken
retested then it means that a lot of
people see
it and it might create some uh momentum
so here we had this download sloping
trendline that is in green because it is
now support that has been broken guys
you know broken here retested and we
went higher so this makes it strong
then i had another one that is actually
that i can do on the longer term all
right
doing the same using the same method and
this one has been broken but not
retested i mean
it didn't hold so it makes it resistance
so we are a bit
uh in a gray area here on the stock so i
would be a buyer around
let's be precise guys around 1180 stop
loss at 11
take profit a bit at 14.60 so you can at
least
not lose money if like you make some
money here and then you got like stopped
later at least you locked some of your
profits
and then of course what we're targeting
is the higher move
guys so here buyer at 11 80
taking profit at 14 18 and then
the next area of resistance i just tried
to see where i have some consolidation
so here we had some all right so that's
why you can
see this was resistance so it hasn't
been broken on daily
you see it never closed above this all
right here it goes here and here it goes
just below
so this is uh 18 our next major
uh resistance level and then second one
is
here this one is not that obvious but
somewhere here so
guys what i would do because i'm not
here to give advice what i would do is
that i would split on the different you
know stocks i'm showing you guys here
and i would split this uh into between
those different targets all right don't
put everything into
one you know split and just you know try
to make smart
trades so buy a low and sell high you
know
it seems obvious but trust me that some
people they're both here
right and you don't want to be there you
don't want to buy just because
of the fomo you buy because you did you
analyze properly
and you follow your own method all right
so skt as i said buyer at 1180
uh taking profits at 15 18 and 26. now
google so this one same thing earnings
going lower it's a
target for the hedge funds they're
shorting the staff massively
we have 44 percent of short interest
once again guys a firm like
apple has only one percent a firm like
tesla where you have a lot of short
interest has
five percent so guys when we have
something around 44
guys it's a lot all right only one
billion of market capitalization though
so it makes like the cash short position
easier to hold for this hedge funds
but once again if all these guys from
reddit uh and
wall street bets and uh all these forums
uh stock tweets
they go here and they can move the price
they can have an impact
so go go this one is quite nice guys
when i say it's nice
because i can see that the waves are
clean you know you don't have that you
know for example
this is not nice you see this is ugly so
this one
i'm just showing you this to show you
what i don't like to analyze all right
when i see this i'm like all right i'm
off the stuff
it's not clean the reactions are not
well
well done all right so it's not good to
uh make some trades you know you can get
stopped uh
you know they have fake breakouts every
every time so this one
uh once again uh same technique uh
downward sloping trendline
we broke it retested it so here the
maximum
level you see that was here guys
this is the reason why here it has
retested this level and we
went higher we didn't go as low as 7
or 720 we went to 8 only
so it shows that like there are a lot of
buyers in this market
and actually it's too late to enter this
one guys so don't buy it right now if
you're not
long you can see that here you see up
this is a level where people start to
take profits so
wait for re-test rate wait at eight guys
don't buy it here
and you can do the same stuff if you go
higher will be test then it becomes
support
then it will turn in green and then you
can buy it here but
guys it's not the right time we don't
have a buying signal at this time
we have a selling signal here right so
this one is not good to buy
but uh it has all the potential to go
higher
but don't buy it here buy it at eight
and stop plus just below all right
all right so i'm done for those two skt
is nice to buy
but lower and google is nice to sell so
that's it for me guys i hope you enjoyed
this video if you did please don't
forget to click the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i talk about this
stuff
and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys